people would come on to send me you guys
needed to get the hell together from the
most extreme coveted protocols in
hollywood to being monitored by netflix
police bringing red notice to life was a
major feat a 200 million dollar one no
less
looking for something specific or just
browsing the chase scenes in red notice
are made that much better by the slick
take on used to zip around and that car
was the real deal in fact two of these
porsches were purchased just for filming
the cars were top-notch performers but
proved to be troublesome when it came
time for the rock to slickly hop into
the vehicle just as johnson was
preparing to enter the car it very
quickly dawned on him that there was no
way his buff body could fit gracefully
i can't get in this car
he says you're kidding me and i went
i'm not dude obviously this was
extremely inconvenient and the director
was far from pleased but where there's a
will there's a way the solution was
slicking dj up in oil so he could slip
into the car and once he was in they
were off while maneuvering his way into
the car doesn't make the cut that's one
scene we definitely want to see when you
see the movie you'll see the scene
starts with like my hand on the shift
and then driving away the question isn't
where was their improv but where wasn't
there every single scene was filled with
improvisation since director ross and
marshall thurber left the actors a lot
of freedom to play with in the film i
know ryan loves to improv and i love
that the open and improvised filled set
wasn't just fun for the performers it
was a significant contributor to making
the film so great with lots of great
improv comes a ton of corpsing you know
we just get the gigs we just start
giggling on set and then we're wasting
everyone's money and time being on set
wound up becoming a kind of a challenge
since most of the time we were just
trying to crack each other up they tried
and they succeeded the hardest part of
filming for gatto was trying not to
crack up in the middle of scenes and we
definitely can't blame her one joke in
particular that came from the mind of
reynolds caught the rock totally off
guard you'll know the reference when you
see it luckily dj took it well and
included the fun moment in the movie for
the audience's enjoyment while it seems
like it was all fun and games making
this movie
well let's just say things got a bit
serious for a hot second they actually
had to police us a little while everyone
loves a fun set netflix were getting a
bit worried that the filming schedule
was going to fall behind and they'd end
up needing to spend more money so they
sent people to literally monitor the
sets and make sure the team stayed on
track after witnessing the magic of the
big tango number between gal gadot and
the rock it's no surprise this was a
favorite for both of them to film the
one scene
it's hard to choose it's hard to choose
the dancing scene while it was a huge
challenge to do it was a very positive
experience that saw the two performers
come together and really support each
other bringing all the performance and
definitely passion don't worry it's
going to be great it's going to be great
it was while godot dove into dancing
with the rock it wasn't without
hesitation the actress insisted the two
rehearse as much as possible one reason
of course being to make it the best
possible but the other was because she
was terrified dj would step on her toes
and crush them you're a big guy
and
my toes are sensitive much to her and
our very delightful surprise
johnson is an incredibly graceful dancer
that anybody would be lucky to partner
with there's no shortage of amazing
stunts in red notice the whole team
rehearsed the intense sequences
thoroughly and in performance ryan
reynolds actually did most of his own
stunts his two stunt doubles were there
to step in when needed but what we see
on screen for the most part is all
reynolds stunt magic i loved shooting a
chase scene that i had with dwayne one
of the most intense stunts for reynolds
came working on the big chase scene
between himself and dwayne johnson
working on four-story scaffolding shook
the actor and left him totally terrified
while filming for about the four or five
days they spent on the sequence the
action is unreal and while he was
shaking in his stunt boots on set
looking back on it reynolds acknowledged
how cool and exhilarating it was
inspector urvashi takes to the screen as
confident and strong as can be and while
ritu arya portrays her brilliantly it
didn't come naturally arya did some
impressive and creative prep work
working out trying rock climbing going
to a gun range
anything the actress could think of that
intimidated her the inspector of course
would have no reservations so arya made
sure she was comfortable enough in
facing daunting experiences to make sure
the confidence vibes came through on
screen with truth you know look in a
movie like this you gotta have a sense
of humor give it to the audience for all
those keen eyes out there be sure to
watch right before any shots come away
because in many instances the actors
burst out laughing soon after because of
a blooper team team
team which feels weird in my mouth but
those bloopers were too good for the
team to ignore approximately 50 percent
of the movie includes tripped up moments
that happen to work in the final cut
perfectly at least the actors held it
together enough so these blooper gems
could be edited in
arrest me halfway through the film we
see gatto dj and reynolds duking it out
in their first three-way battle it's one
of our favorites to watch and was one of
director ross and marshall thurber's
favorite scenes to shoot getting the
chance to work on such an epic sequence
with three stars resulted in magic this
was essentially a chance for thurber to
just enjoy and revel in the brilliant
talent of such skilled performers
it's kind of impossible to ignore how
unbelievable it is to have a heist movie
with these three stars at the center the
real-life relationships definitely
contributed to the fun dynamics on
screen we're like an old couple with big
stars come big paychecks
worth over 20 million dollars 20 million
dollars for each of the actors that is
no wonder the film budget was 200
million we're not surprised that each of
the leads were actually thurber's first
choices
before he'd even finished the script the
idea was pitched to the rock who no
surprise loved it and said yes
immediately in thurber's mind no one
could play gato's part except the
actress herself so he casually flew to
london to pitch her on it she agreed to
sign on reynolds was the final piece of
the puzzle and the only one who has
actually sent the script to read we
imagine the actor could see himself
doing the part upon reading especially
since the role of the world's greatest
con man was written with reynolds in
mind he joined the project the morning
after reading this movie has really been
a long time coming just over half was
filmed before the pandemic hit they
began in january 2020 and faced some
delays on their international travel
plans when borders started closing up
and soon after the team decided to pause
production for two weeks
that eventually turned into a much
longer break but the team came back
together in september 2020 to finish
what they'd started we came back to
shoot as uh
right in the middle of the pandemic
filming finished in the place where they
were first interrupted italy the team
said that's a wrap and chow on november
18 2020. unfortunately during the break
in production the rock and his entire
family had come down with covid19 after
experiencing the pandemic very close to
home the rock himself insisted the team
go above and beyond to protect the
production team and red notice implied
the most aggressive coveted measures in
hollywood
as we've all had to deal with the
pandemic i and i know i could speak for
gal on this so really so proud of our
crew the cast and crew became very well
versed in testing and nose swabs zones
and bubbles in fact 800 cast and crew
members collectively underwent a
whopping 2 000 tests per week all these
guidelines could be found in one of the
many hundreds of pages long manuals on
the set all that work paid off since
there wasn't a single outbreak in the
entire production netflix definitely
made a smart investment in this
unbelievable team who made a fun and
action-packed movie all while laughing
and joking together on set even if they
were on occasion being policed